bild 01 12 385 beata mega data hat
allerdings wieder mal waren und
willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute geht es um fashion denn ich denke
wer wie ein snack aussieht sollte auch
über fischen reden können wie hat amazon
vorgeschlagen dass ich doch mal die
fashion abteilung auschecken soll und
dann ist mir zum ersten mal der gedanke
gekommen auf amazon kaufen die leute
kleidung nicht falsch verstehen ihr
könnt gerne eure klamotten auf amazon
kaufen nur für mich war das immer so ein
ding dass meine mutter da klamotten
gekauft hat die immer wirklich sehr
uncool war wenn ich das jetzt mal so
sagen kann also ich fand sie immer
furchtbar und dachte mir immer näher
also amazon ist also wie qvc so alte
menschen klamottenladen im internet aber
ich wäre nicht vanessa wenn wir das
heute nicht testen würden kann man auch
amazon coole fashion mode trends kaufen
und die viel wichtigere frage kann man
auch geld dabei sparen also wie bei den
elektronikgeräten zum beispiel wenn ich
habe amazon etwas elektronisches hole es
ist eigentlich immer günstiger als im
laden oder überall anders ist es bei den
klamotten genauso ich habe die antwort
für euch eine auswahl die amazon direkt
erstellt hat die edits unsere auswahl
der besten style des monats frühlings
kleiner übergangs stiefel what we're das
fashion einmal ein dann noch leichte
jacken breite cirio zu holen werde das
beste der neuen mode umhängetasche ein
wilder mix von amazon und einen versuch
dir etwas zu verkaufen wir gehen schritt
für schritt die kategorien durch denn
ich habe auch dinge dort bestellt wie es
kategorie die interessantesten band the
what we're also das fashion einmal
was sagt uns amazon was betragen sollen
denn dieser kategorie waren viele blusen
zu sehen und vor allem schuhe die ich
überhaupt nicht schön fahren aber ein
teil habe ich dann doch gefunden und
zwar diese gelbe bluse von mit zelt ich
habe diese marke noch nie gehört ehrlich
gesagt sie kostet dort 15 euro 60 und
dann habe ich mal geschaut ob es sie
noch woanders gibt und tatsächlich
verkauft sie auch zalando und die miss
hellfritsch seite selbst auch zalando
kostet diese bluse immer noch 40 euro 95
und auf der eigenen webseite wird diese
bluse 540 euro angeboten das ist über
die hälfte die man sich sparen wenn es
bei amazon holt weil sie und weil sie
mir so gut gefallen hat habe ich sie
natürlich gekauft
eine sache hat mich interessiert und
zwar ob das nicht vielleicht einfach
eine fälschung ist ich weiß nicht warum
sie eine fälschung drin haben sollten
von einer marke die jetzt auch nicht so
riesig ist aber es sieht mir nach dem
original aus es ist meine britische
marke dann hier ist der fund preis ganz
groß 28 sofort auf amazon ein
schnäppchen ich verlinke euch die ganzen
klamotten unten einmal in der video
beschreibung falls ihr das haben wollt
euch anschauen wollt preise vergleichen
wollte keine ahnung
ok der stopp ist jetzt leichter fünf
frühling wie schön das schmeiße ich mir
doch direkt dran war gesenkt
[Musik]
ein sechster mann nicht der essen hat es
ist sehr gut und sehr kurz aber so
tragen dass die kinder heutzutage da
muss man einfach mitmachen
blasenentzündung hin oder her es muss
klar sein glaube ich dass jetzt auch
einfach an eine sache ist mir noch sehr
aufgefallen und zwar die präsentation
der klamotten auf der eigenen webseite
hast du ein schönes bild wo ein mädel
dieses oberteil an hat bei zalando sieht
das genauso aufregend aus und auf amazon
hast du als ein halbes topmodel was
irgendwie diese sachen so präsentiert
als ob das arbeitsklamotten oder so
keine ahnung ist auf jeden fall nicht
fashion also aber so wenn ihr noch
verschicker sein wollt und günstig
verkaufen wollt dann bitte bessere
präsentationen dankeschön kommen wir zu
der kategorie frühlings kleider da habe
ich einige interessante sachen gefunden
allerdings nicht wirklich was ich tragen
würde dann bin ich auf das kleid von der
marke jennifer gestoßen und das fand ich
ganz gut allerdings habe ich kein google
eintrag zu dieser marke bekommen außer
der amazon shop und ich denke das ist
dann einfach eine marke die nur auf
amazon verkauft dann habe ich dieses
kleid bestellt für 19 euro
83 was nirgendwo anders auftaucht und
jetzt schauen wir mal nach der qualität
fehlt mir bist du denn fa
dieses kleine farm myp2p warum
ja aber das ist doch süß das hat diesen
stoff diesen geräten stoff der so ein
bisschen fester ist das mag ich war dann
sieht man die speckröllchen nicht so das
liegt dann lieber darüber nicht so dran
ja die qualität ist völlig in ordnung
ich würde glaube ich h & m qualität
nennen positiv überrascht cooles kleid
danke
das ist das was ich verstehe wenn
das zweite frühlings kleid ist ein rosa
kleid mit stickerei drauf die strauße
darstellen sollen wenn ich an den
frühling denke denke ich natürlich
sofort an strauss also wollte ich das
auch unbedingt haben und diese marke
jeep allofs existiert sogar neben dem
amazon kostenlos lieber los klang hat
schon wieder nach so viva con agua warm
aber tatsächlich haben ein wirklich
schön online shop und noch dazu eine
ziemlich fans wie instagram seite mit
33.000 voll war und die bilder sind
wirklich schön und dann kommt wieder
amazon der schnäppchen meist um die ecke
mit 38 eur 36 für dieses kleid und dabei
kostet es auf der webseite auf 54 eur 60
schlag und hätte mich sehr gespannt weil
die preise verheißen ja schon dass es
eine gute qualität sein sollte und das
testen wir wissen wie schwer das ist ich
habe diese sachen bestellt zwei tage
später waren sie bei mir und ich dachte
sie nicht aufmachen und anschauen weil
ich dieses video drehen wollte youtuber
sein ist so anstrengend
ist das ein krasses kleid mein gott
sieht aus wie auf so einem wind schlagen
also es hat einmal original 78 euro
gekostet ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man die
78 euro erkennen sollte aber ist es auf
jeden fall hochwertiger als das und das
schwarze kleid das sie schmeißt es mir
einfach wieder drauf und bemerkte dann
das ist ziemlich hässlich ist
beziehungsweise ist nicht hässlich es
ist halt viel zu eng
es ist ganz süß das muss ich sagen aber
es ist halt irgendwie fühlte sich wie
eine rosa leberwurst presswurst mit
straußen drauf oder schokolade seiten
besser als ich hab eine 38 gekauft und
ich bin auch wirklich eine 38 es hat
sich angefühlt wie 36 leicht sind die
spanier ein bisschen schmaler kommen die
aber zum nächsten punkt jacke die
meisten jecken auf amazon haben wir echt
gut gefallen es sollen ja leichte
frühlings jacken sein denn der winter
ist vorbei und jetzt kommen wir langsam
in den frühling und da habe ich diese
jacke von new look gefunden die sieht
auch auf dem bild ehrlich gesagt nicht
so warm auf und 37 eur 65 finde jack ist
jetzt wirklich ein guter preise ist es
nicht teuer aber zalando hatte sie
günstiger dafür 34 95 es ist nicht viel
aber es ist günstiger und ich dachte zu
landesrecht bei allem über teurer und
hier steht wintermantel auf amazon wird
sie als leichte jacke angeboten und hier
als wintermantel
deswegen musste ich sie unbedingt holen
auch wenn sie mir sehr gut gefallen hat
besonders die zalando bilder denn auch
da amazon sieht das wieder bisschen aus
wie so here's the jacket von new york
diese prosa aber auf unserer website
wird sie weiß aus so und eigentlich
wollte ich jetzt nur auf amazon sachen
bestellen und dani mode testen aber wenn
wir die jacke so gut gefallen hat und
sie auf verlangen einfach günstiger war
habe ich sie auch zur landung besteht
und die gucken jetzt auch uns einmal
zusammen hahaha kennt ihr noch die
werbung
okay das ist definitiv keine leichte
jacke für frühling vori fühlt sich gut
an
aus dem kissen
ich fühle mich wie vom dickes kissen ort
ist voll war ein bisschen zu warm für
drin aber das ist schön
[Musik]
ich denke dass alles sein das könnte
wasser sein
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nein
die jacke wird definitiv behalten ich
finde sie super super weich vielleicht
stehen viele nicht auf diesen oversize
look also dieses versinken in einer
jacke ich mag das sehr gerne und das ist
einfach eine tolle kommen wir mal zu den
handtaschen bei den handtaschen war ich
wirklich verwirrt bei mir nur taschen
vorgeschlagen wurden die extrem teuer
waren von love machine oder anderen
großen marken waren dabei war das andere
angebot so durch gemixten bis hin zu
winzigen müssen was zum teureren und
hier was wirklich so handtasche 300 euro
hier 200 euro 100 das was ich meine es
war echt so wer sich das kaufen wenn ich
mir eine tasche für 300 euro kaufen
möchte dann kauf ich sie doch nicht bei
amazon
dann gehe ich in den laden und holen sie
mir dort weil das will ich dann doch
auch noch haben dieses gefühl wenn ich
mir irgendwann mal was von gucci holen
möchte dann werde ich nicht den online
store besuchen oder irgendwo das online
kaufen sondern ich würde es gut hier
eingehen sagen ich will bitte main
champagner bin ich werde jetzt ein t
shirt für 500 euro kaufen oder ein paar
schuhe für 800 euro und dann mache ich
noch zur krönung eine story time dass
ich nie wieder in diesem budget store
gehe weil ich würde mir in meinem leben
vielleicht nur einmal 800 euro schuhe
kaufen mich dann den rest meines lebens
dafür hassen dass ich 800 euro für
schuhe ausgegeben habe aber zurück zu
den amazon handtaschen ich habe mir
keine gekauft weil es mir einfach zu
teuer ein und hefte wie youtube manier
to heaven is more you tube money where
you can afford to freezing that you eat
the dog kowald stay on your level im
sommer wenn du in der eu bahnsteigs und
kleidern hast musst du wirst dein kleid
so runterziehen
aber sonst setzt du dann hast du ein
bisschen
sessel und dann schwitzt du mit diesen
werken
ok
nächstes
[Musik]